so what was this you you you sent this
over to me
um well well first off let's give credit
to comedic clips put this up
uh it's theo vaughn and bill burr most
awkward moments
i guess they bill bill burr was
promoting his netflix special or
something
yeah uh this um he's been doing the
rounds or whatever i guess doing
podcasts and [ __ ] his new special yeah i
saw him on rogan
uh i think he's a little worried because
the chappelle one was so big and i think
bill knows already that he's
just overshadowed this round right bad
timing so he's out just doing a push
so he goes and does your mom's not your
mom's house whatever this weekend
king fighter sting guy um but we're just
just theo fonz solo podcast
just theo van yeah it's the this weekend
past
whatever whatever [ __ ] theo's 19
podcast when he does by himself
um and bill just gets nasty with him
really yeah at first like i i'll let you
kind of be
you know decide on your own here but
because i at first thought like all
right he's breaking balls to bill burr
but after a while i'm like what are you
doing
it gets really yeah it gets very weird
but yeah that's i just had to i just
took some
did some dates off of the bucks i was i
got a bunch of stress man i was starting
to lose my mind i thought
oh yeah no that's it affects everybody
differently so
i just uh oh your neck's getting old
there billy boy
that old man neck yeah i just there's a
good thing too is just lie and just say
you're not available that way yeah i'm
not in town
oh i already had them sold and i had to
take them down oh that gee i wouldn't
put that on the podcast yeah they know
they all know yeah i still wouldn't do
that oh cause you don't know you don't
need bookers looking at that this guy's
always a [ __ ] wild card
but i was just like experienced like a
ton of stress man burnt that wasn't that
bad
it's out first you know i've been on the
same tour for this hour for almost over
a year now
um dude bands tour for like four years
and then [ __ ] go right back in the
studio make another one and keep going
you got to toughen up man yeah you're
right huh
you know what do you want to [ __ ]
still light heartedly that's still just
burpee and burn yeah yeah yeah tough it
up come on
slush hat looking like a [ __ ]
backwoods guy all tough and [ __ ] you
can't handle
doing your hour again i mean come on man
suck it up
sometimes he would put like a tarp over
it at night and stuff i think during
like maybe
i guess the spring or something but i
think otherwise it was just
just one option open you know just
cruise at any point can i promote that i
have a special out here yeah
now now this is where look at this is
like now the facial
expressions are changing the posture has
changed is that about
kind of weird right really nasty and
this was now i want to point out because
i know it's a montage so people are like
well maybe this is an hour into it or
whatever
this was about five to ten minutes into
the pocket like this was just
five minutes in i believe was what i was
told i was doing that
i don't know where we're going with this
all right i have a special i need a
solid oak table by the way if you don't
mind
that's not very good looking table like
that looks like the kind of table you'll
get splinters from
yeah you're allowed on that's streaming
now on netflix for
linda mccartney yeah she lost her arm
right
no she died yeah has that place been
around for a couple hundred years
uh since the mid-1800s oh jesus
yeah some guy uh it was probably the
prince albert no prince albert
dude i love how you're just [ __ ]
reaching for [ __ ] a couple thousand
years it's been around napoleon
that's an old guy okay now it's
all right it's beyond just because now
bill bird does have that kind of at
first it
the first thing to me wasn't nasty
because that was banter that's
you know if roy said to me like yeah i'm
torn doing stand up doing this hour
every night i'm just like burn out man
i'm so worn out i cancelled some shows
i would be going you can't [ __ ] go
yeah oh good stage with a bottle of
water do my [ __ ] hour and get you a
couple grand and go back to the hotel
and eat a bowl of ice cream you [ __ ]
lazy piece of [ __ ] that was fine but
then yeah
then the at any point can i promote my
spa and then
just it starts sparking out we're a
minute 36 into a how long
seven minute compilation yeah i guess i
kind of treasure the things that i do do
comedically
for just say you treasure what you do
like literally your ass yeah you're
worried that some big hollywood director
you can't take your comedic skills and
say what the [ __ ] somebody else wrote
you treasure your act so much is that
what you're trying to tell the way that
i present it man
the way that i present it if i give
somebody something if i do something
funny it's like
yeah i'm going to leave it up to some
[ __ ] that i feel like doesn't know
how to best this dude is going to be so
theo van is basically saying he doesn't
want to sell out his comedy
and i think bill burr is like just
[ __ ] s is that was that that was that
backbone
yeah i think bill burr is taking f is
for family dog i mean he's done some
selling out
he's such a nightmare when he makes it i
treasure these jokes how dare you this
this
what do they call it this is this is
vulgar this edit is vulgar
like i have a tough time working i just
think i have a tough time working with
other people sometimes you know
which is one of the reasons why i got
into comedy anyway you know what this is
i would say get over that yeah get over
yourself and get over that because
there's a lot of great people in this
business and you're going to miss out
and uh i don't know
what you'll say your loved ones will
save money on the funeral costs because
no one's going to go so there's not
gonna be too many [ __ ]
snacks they gotta put together
[Laughter]
she'd have a rough day and she'd come in
and i don't remember the whole show i
can explain it to you yeah
if i can explain it like a guy just i
don't know what that is all right
i don't know i don't know and the second
okay so all right look i'll even say
this up until even the last couple
i was like hey he's being kind of a dick
but he still feels like banter to me
i want to be honest but now this but now
this this is like
i'll explain it to you he's getting to
the point where yeah
guy he's getting to that point where if
you were a guy at a bar
you're now putting your [ __ ] hand
you're putting your hand on people's
shoulders
yeah you know where it starts getting
like now even you're touching something
that lasts like you're not
dude you keep you [ __ ] keep getting
cute
that last one it's it's kind of trying
to be the alphabet yeah she's trying to
alpha male 1 sounds like
a kid yeah i started to explain like i
don't know the whole show
all right i get it i get it i believe is
that comic add like i i don't even
[ __ ]
i'm not into it i don't want to hear it
i got it your show go ahead continue
this is starting to feel i'm feeling
uncomfortable now for real now this is
about three minutes in now is when i'm
like
you will agree right i could be a pretty
obnoxious guy sometimes right
yeah sometimes occasionally occasionally
very rarely
all the time um if if if you saw a clip
right if you just one night if i said
like oh i'm going to be doing this guy's
podcast whatever he doesn't have a lot
of viewers but like you know whatever
big fan of the show and i go and do a
podcast and clips start coming back to
you right like of me
treating anyone like like [ __ ] yeah
wouldn't you go like
what was your [ __ ] problem with that
guy like you know where are you doing
something to you
because i've seen because i've seen burr
on other shows
like he wasn't like this to rogan no he
wasn't like this to conan and there's a
way to banter and break
you can do other people's show i mean we
always [ __ ] with joe coletta
and uh there's other people that like we
you know we've always gone uh hammy when
we used to do stuff with him
these guys we would bust their chops but
like
there's a level where it goes okay man
now you're
now he's being disrespectful to me man
you're being disrespectful the other
thing is
i i kind of feel at some point theo
van's a comic he should have defended
himself a little bit
that bus is nice bust his balls back
he's too nice and
remember uh all right let's talk about
old shows then we don't have to i just
was it was so funny how you [ __ ] you
bailed twice on that patty duke made me
feel like an [ __ ] like that was the
15th time i [ __ ] brought it up
sorry i kind of feel like you have a lot
of internalized anger and maybe because
you're not super happy with your
marriage bill
i don't know no i'm just saying if i
were to guess
that's no a lot of dudes that are like
this in real life like you
you we've all known everybody listening
has known somebody like this
who's having issues with his wife and
then when they go out they kind of snap
at you and you're like hey bro what
you're right we're
trying to domineer people because
they're getting people yeah like what's
what's wrong bud
don't take that [ __ ] out it's not my
fault yeah yeah
no mary tyler moore one of the great
ensemble [ __ ] cast of all time
i do know she just died recently uh yeah
i mean i was gonna bring up a more
positive story about the show but yeah
it's the second time hey bill hey theo
this is marissa from raleigh north
carolina
so bill i heard you say on i believe it
was joe rogan's podcast that you really
like the film once upon a time in
hollywood and you've seen it several
times
and i know theo said that he walked out
halfway through it
um so i was just wondering maybe if you
could talk about why you loved it so
much and
theo why you walked out halfway through
it
anyway gang gang well this is where bill
and i
don't talk anymore after this no no i if
you didn't like it he didn't like it
i absolutely [ __ ] loved it i heard on
your podcast you say that you loved it
oh my god
dude it's the best work uh leo's i mean
brad pitt's great first time he watched
it
i was just like i want to be like brad
pitt's the guy i want to be yeah and
then the second time i watched i was
like oh my god i'm just like leo's
character i have an emotional [ __ ]
mess
well i don't know what part you walked
out in but i walked out after they went
to that house for the first time after
they met the old guy
and they were in the yard and then his
car was had a flat tire
and at that point i was like i got to
get out of here i don't know what these
guys are doing you know i felt like it
was just kind of a waste of
i don't know it just i couldn't get into
it and i didn't know what was going on
you know you say it all the time he's
theo's look theo's and
i'm not i will we we obviously make fun
of we
even will make fun of the sting in the
bing or the bing and the bong we're used
to making fun of brendan but
theo i do think is a nice guy i will
honestly say that i feel like he's
genuinely nice
there's there's an earnest a joe dirk
vibe to him
yes exactly he's a joe dirt vibe to him
he's a nice guy he really is i want to
be emphatic about that
but he's not super smart no he's not at
all but
this is i was saying this the other
night too on nightwave like
this moment right here it encapsulates
why i
cannot hate theovan because he's
actually being vulnerable in this moment
and being nice and going
yeah man it was like i just didn't get
the movie and i felt really stupid
and i felt like everyone around me was
like way smarter than me and i felt dumb
and intimidated
and he's looking down and going like
yeah and i felt like intimidated so like
i left
and you would think like all right you
can't break his balls in that moment
you're like yeah you should be a likable
guy
i'm starting to wonder like look at bill
burr is i guess he could be kind of
being a big
i feel like this is the way bill burr
would talk to like one of those even
let's say he was doing bob kelly's show
podcast like they're friends right
that he would talk to him like be like
this and bob kelly would go back at him
and kind of you know be snippy back
it'll be
him and vos like there's a bunch of bill
burr and patrice when they used to go at
it with each other like
you know they used to give this just
kind of feels one-sided it feels like
bloopers coming in all hot
and theology's like yeah man i'm just
not a big tarantino fan
i'm more of a michael bay guy you know
did you see fast eight but you don't but
bill should know better if he's a
professional than to go into a show with
this like
junior no no i'm not saying he knows
better not he's doing the circuit
it's it's like back in the day you know
this mike like back in the day comics
had to do all the fm shows right like
if you were doing a town you have to go
and sell your tickets it's the same
thing with netflix you got to promote it
so like you know i'm sure they're
telling them
look these are the shows you got to go
on i'm sure and i believe the only
reason he's on theo vaughn's show is
because of the joe rogan connection
rogan was probably like hey man
yeah man i have you on no problem can
you do me a favor though i got these
other shows like it's just it's
it's like you know it's in the same
building yeah we'll bang them all out so
can you like do theos
also and um that would be great
and maybe brian callan you could do his
too like i think that's the reason this
is happening
this wouldn't normally be something that
i think would just i just meant in terms
of him knowing better i just think that
bill
like knows he's not going into ona this
isn't guys that you've known for years
and you're coming in and going like
dude can you believe this [ __ ] [ __ ]
lassa out in the hallway this [ __ ]
idiot told me like
like they were just brutal to each other
exposing each other's secrets and [ __ ]
just being mean because they were all
friends but he just came in here and
just started shredding theo until i was
like
yeah man i just didn't get the movie
it's weird it went on and it made me
feel uncomfortable it's like i got to
get out of here because i started to
feel like
everybody knows what's going on and i
don't know what's going on you know i
guess
yeah he's just he's too earnest being
honest
god's damn deal don't like the other
you're just being nice he's just like
look man i don't get this this is
impossible
to hate this guy there wasn't even any
explosions i'm like what am i gonna do
here you know what else he kind of
reminds me of dewey crow
dewey crowe right from justified does he
not see stewie crow
i'm sorry raylan i just didn't get it
you know i do want to watch that hobbs
and shaw movie
now that looks good there's explosions
in it hey man you watch transformers
i like look i celebrate the rock's
entire catalog
everything going back to wrestlemania x7
brother right
before that intercontinental champion
bill bears like the [ __ ] you talking
about
theo looks like somebody who has a
transformers box set
you know what i mean yeah and a receipt
for it from two weeks ago yes
all right well i got my weekend planned
out i'm the therapist buddy
yeah if that happens to you at the
[ __ ] movies if you think the whole
movie
the whole movie theater gives a [ __ ]
about whether
no i don't think you're making are you
making like audible noises that you do
oh
whoa oh my god that's the only way they
would know
[ __ ] man i don't know it's so [ __ ] up
mandy yeah you do
do you keep a weapon on yours or no on
what in your
uh i don't know if you have a helicopter
if you rent a helicopter i really have
to answer that he knows god damn well i
don't have a weapon why are you doing
this
you don't you don't have a gun i don't
think that's i i don't think that's
obtuse really to think you might have a
weapon in there with you
think about it yeah think about it okay
you think about it
you don't fly around your helicopter
with machine gun because man i would
love to do that if i had a helicopter
you know in louisiana where i'm from
it's actually legal to own a machine gun
and mount it on a helicopter
they actually give you a tax break they
actually tax you more if you don't have
one of them
just a small gun dude as a hand piece
yeah no okay fine nice breitling
fine bill that's just a [ __ ]
ridiculous question
i thought you're bringing oozy up there
with your flaps well one thing
definitely is i've made more money even
just in the past year i finally started
making money you know
and it's definitely been like yeah
sometimes even in the beginning of this
evening he's going to start yelling at
himself in the mirror like leo
and the part before you walked out was
it really [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yeah oh he yells at himself in the
mirror it's one of my favorite seats um
maybe i got to watch it where did it
just completely derail is
yeah so this whole thing is so weird to
me it's uncomfortable i'm uncomfortable
uncomfortable
but again yeah you you yeah you don't
have to i don't want to force
well i'm not going to watch it because
you want me to watch it but i'll watch
it maybe because maybe i did miss
something you know i just at a certain
point i'm just like
my favorite part of it was that brad
pitt had a little bit of like a hitch in
his walk a little bit if you noticed
that
what about leo with the with the speech
impediment that only happened
off yeah man but i work i do a podcast
with someone with a speech impediment
and it's like it's not really a vacation
if i have to listen to somebody
else when i'm watching a movie i love
how you just dismissed that
yeah oh my god that's amazing that's
what's amazing about when somebody
makes something like people's reaction
like oh my god this is the greatest
thing ever something else
hey [ __ ] walked out i got nervous the
whole movie theater
was listening to my inner thoughts
that's pretty funny they care they care
this much about me
i don't think they care i [ __ ] care
in my head i care too much
when i put the hat on that means i gotta
go that's fine i want to show you my
truck
all right all right we got so we can
bond on something we can agree we we
missed the mark
on mary tyler moore yep you brought it
up
family man have you seen that movie i've
seen family guy
what about uh the nice guys oh
you gotta see that these are just two
people that have nothing in common
okay you gotta see that one that's a
funny one gilbert's like theovon's dad
that he never saw his whole life
i mean and they met on facebook and now
they're meeting up at like a diner
no i don't know i think you like me
you're looking down you got you
all out you got your job it's very
confrontational i'm feeling like you're
not liking my suggestions
i just like you you like to america once
upon a time in hollywood this guy's dead
to me
he's dead to me just to let you know i
can't hear your inner thoughts so don't
get all [ __ ] weirded out
and just walk out crazy like you're in
my head man
um so you also sent me this one little
clip that this guy left out and he
really should have left us in
uh let's check it out yeah you came
dog just had the dog was like a bouncer
you if you got grandfathered in and you
were cool and then once you
anything after that was like no who the
[ __ ] is this this person needs to be
terminated did you
ever uh you ever donated sperm or
anything like that when you were coming
up as a comedian
nope and i don't have a gun in my
helicopter but i want to thank you for
having me
you bet and help me promote my special i
just have to get home don't worry it's
my kid's getting up from the nap and
it's my watch
i love it i love your editing and i love
everything that you're doing i'm so
happy for you
thanks man what's he doing
you're always supportive you're doing it
just expand don't be afraid to get into
business with people get a good lawyer
all right all right thanks bill thank
you
normally when a podcast ends you end
with both people on camera and then
after you go
hey man thanks so much he was actually
just standing up
and walking out oh it's disrespectful
man i like every i like everything
you're doing
i must leave now i'm not white knighting
for theovan i'm not a fan of theovon's
comedy or anything
but i don't hate him though he just
seems like in a world
of really really hateable people
and then there's just theo vaughn and
sam tripoli
out there floating around right that are
still mildly redeemable you're like
ah you know look out of 300 of those
comedians out there there's two that i'd
actually go
so and so said you want to go meet them
but actually you want to go hang out
with that part like
i'd go with theovan or sam tripley they
seem to
at least have retained a bit of their
humanity but they're awash and to see
these [ __ ]
sociopaths and narcissists